laurent jalabert est en direct avec nous
de lescar dans les pyrénées atlantiques
laurent jalabert quelle étape 162 km en
solitaire s'y colle dans la journée tout
seul ce soir le maillot à pois du
meilleur grimpeur pour la première fois
de votre carrière et vous allez nous
faire croire vous n'êtes pas un
spécialiste de la montagne
oui si j'avais été un genre attendre le
final et j'aurais essayé de gagner au
sommet aujourd'hui mais bon c'est vrai
que je suis pas non plus minables en
montagne mais bon j'ai besoin si je veux
gagner de d'attaquer de loin comme ça
c'était bien tenté j'ai pris des gros
risques mais mais c'était ce prix là que
j'avais une chance de gagner aujourd'hui
alors gros risques on va revoir l'image
vous avez été victime d'une chute c'est
quoi une justement une trop grande prise
de risques dans la descente où
finalement une grande fatigue vraiment
là précisément la descente était
terminée
c'était surtout la fatigue de la gîte
est moins lucide dans la dernière
descente j'ai fait une petite erreur de
freinage quoi j'ai trop bloquer les
frères l'avoir je vais partir en
victoire d'étape pour lance armstrong
qui vous rattrape in extremis caisse
conso qu'est ce qu'on ressent à ce
moment là après 162 kilomètres seul
c'est quoi c'est un grand courant d'air
qui passe ce thème courant dépasse et
vite
bon même s'il m'a fait signe à la terre
à 18 mois non je me prends il m'aurait
fallu autre chose qu'un vélo pour
moindres carrés avec lui mais bon c'est
comme ça c'est le destin
c'est vrai que c'était difficile d'aller
au bout mais j'ai quand même fait une
belle journée sur une belle étape
je suis très content de ma journée alors
public considérable dans les pyrénées
aujourd'hui on vous a vu à certains
moments manifester votre énervement à
l'égard de certains kibaki vous à rose
qui vous pousse qui vous tape même si
c'est sympathique ça ça énerve parfois
non mais en règle générale je suis resté
très calme aujourd'hui je n'ai pas eu de
problème avec le public
bien au contraire si ce n'est peut-être
qu'une fois ou deux où on m'a rouge avec
de l'eau trop froide et ça surprend un
petit peu mais mais bon rien de bien
grave
oui c'est vrai que c'est une popularité
énorme pour vous on a vu beaucoup de
panneaux et affiches à votre nom alors
deux victoires d'étapes dont celle du 14
juillet ce maillot du meilleur grimpeur
pour la première fois on vous souhaite
de le conserver encore demain soir quoi
qu'il arrive ce tour restera un grand
cru pour vous oui tout à fait c'est
scissionner le meilleur c'est notre
meilleur et bon quoi qu'il arrive et
jusqu'à paris c'est clair mais bon je
vais essayer encore de faire quelque
chose de bien ici à la fin on vous le
souhaite merci beaucoup laurent jalabert
vous étiez en direct avec nous